[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález la inestabilidad
política vuelve a poner al tee en la
lupa de la comunidad internacional
preocupa mucho la división social y
política que hay en ese país un
presidente aferrado al poder asegurando
que como su mandato comenzó un tiempo
después por irregularidades en las
elecciones entonces tiene que terminar
un tiempo después una oposición que
intenta también conformar un gobierno
transitorio una sociedad sumergida en
necesidades en la falta de oportunidades
y con muchas dificultades para hacer
frente a la pandemia del cubil 19 un
intento de golpe de estado en el
escenario abogados académicos la iglesia
los empresarios pidiendo el fin del
mandato del presidente joven el mois
quien ha recibido como lo hemos visto el
respaldo de varios organismos
internacionales y también de algunos
países como por ejemplo eeuu un complejo
escenario que no es ajeno a la historia
haitiana la crisis política de haití es
nuestro tema de hoy en el debate de
france 24 y los pongo en contexto con el
siguiente reportaje veamos
la camioneta de una emisora de radio
envuelta en gas lacrimógeno y otros
periodistas aplicando primeros auxilios
a sus compañeros mientras las protestas
siguen creciendo la policía haitiana ha
sido acusada de una violenta represión
que incluso ha tenido como objetivo a
miembros de la prensa claramente
identificados
las tensiones aumentan en haití con la
población exigiendo la dimisión del
presidente yo en el móvil
[Música]
el mandatario joven el moisés está
llegando a su fin no volveremos a la
dictadura
los opositores argumentan que su mandato
presidencial terminó el domingo
sitios desde antes del 7 de febrero la
situación es grave y después de esta
fecha el presidente perdió toda la
legitimidad porque su mandato ha
terminado la situación se ha agravado y
la dictadura empeora
el presidente moix argumenta sin embargo
que juró su mandato de cinco años en
2017 por lo que todavía tiene el poder
hasta febrero de 2022
eeuu ha respaldado esta postura aunque
su embajada emitió un comunicado en el
que dice estar profundamente preocupada
por cualquier acción que pueda dañar las
instituciones democráticas de haití el
domingo funcionarios leales al
presidente afirmaron haber frustrado un
intento de golpe de estado contra él y
arrestaron a 23 personas entre ellas un
juez del tribunal supremo quien obtuvo
este jueves su orden de liberación el
martes moix trató de sacar del cargo a
otros tres jueces que fueron propuestos
como posibles líderes nacionales
interinos por la oposición complejo
panorama y para analizarlo hemos
invitado a colette lespinasse ella es
periodista y analista también es
educadora de los derechos humanos y
servicios sociales ella se encuentra
la ciudad de puerto príncipe la capital
haitiana y también está con nosotros
ricardo seitenfus ls profesor
universitario fue representante de la
organización de estados américanos allí
en haití en el año 2009 y nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de brasilia la capital
brasileña que es el recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar sus preguntas dejar los
comentarios en las redes sociales se la
recuerda estamos en facebook también no
se encuentran en instagram y en twitter
como france24
y arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal pueden dejar los comentarios
con la etiqueta numeral el debate
efe 24 comenzamos comienzo entonces
preguntándole a colette allí en la
ciudad de puerto príncipe la pregunta
básica que se hace todo el mundo a esta
hora es legítimo colette ese reclamo que
hace el presidente lleven el móvil de
querer permanecer por lo menos un año
más en el cargo argumentando que como su
mandato comenzó tarde pues termina tarde
buenas noches a todos y todas que vas
estar mirando y buenas noches también a
usted ya sr piq a los cristianos que
tiene mucho fama en la xxi y es una
persona muy bien
en este debate con el bueno
no todos los haitianos y todas las
instituciones
comparten la misma opinión del
presidente o ex presidente depende de
quién está hablando ahora son del país
porque para mucha gente y no solamente
personal de la calle que está dando sus
opiniones sino instituciones muy
importantes como por ejemplo la
celebración de las asociaciones de
abogados como por ejemplo gente que
habían participado en la redacción de la
constitución o gente de universidades
entre la iglesia canta o distante mucha
gente han dicho que sí y definición del
mandatario de su poder morir en el 7 de
febrero es decir inviten domingo pasado
porque hay artículos en la cuarta
corrupción que dice que sí aunque
empezó su mandatario el 7 de febrero de
2017 pero según la constitución
hay un círculo de años para las
elecciones y para la entrada de un
presidente sí y él también empezó a
reconocer eso cuando había dicho que se
venció el mandatario de los celadores
entonces ahora vamos tú su turno y en lo
quiere aceptar lo que él había observado
para el parlament plan y por eso para
mucha gente se terminó su mandato pero
sus partidarios y es también dice va lo
tiene que dar de poder atrás 22 de enero
[Música]
así es que dependiendo de la perspectiva
de dónde se mire para unos terminó el
mandato para otros no
y le hago la misma pregunta al señor
ricardo seitenfus en en brasilia para
usted es legítimo este reclamo es decir
estos argumentos que le hemos presentado
en el reportaje que también explicaba
colette son válidos para que el
presidente piense que puede permanecer
un año más en el poder pese a la gran
crisis política que esto está generando
allí
una buena es un placer participar de
este debate yo creo que todo es un falso
problema porque cuando nosotros miramos
la historia reciente de haití desde el
haití está buscando siempre una
estabilidad
hubo 10 misiones incluso una operación
de paz de naciones unidas a lo largo de
este es 30 33 años que siempre es
anciano y colectas lo sabe muy bien
siempre el problema central de las
crisis que nos nueva hambre
no es
el analfabetismo no es desempleo
recuerdo 60% de la gente no tiene
puestos de trabajo
siempre es un problema político
constitucional electoral
entonces hay dos artículos
reconstitución es una concepción de 87
que dice exactamente 1 la razón a rodear
mismo otorga razón a la oposición pero
que es un falso problema porque que la
oposición no se prepara este año para
ver la de la campaña electoral en grande
las elecciones con el bajo grado la
presidencia con el voto desde 2010 la
cola internacional
interior una elección de 2010 2011
después de la reelección del joven a la
primera y la segunda es normal y
someterse que de cinco años
pero es no es un problema serio es un
problema para crear un clima de
habilidad un clima político difícil
porque porque se quiere sentir nicolás
una única cosa si quiere una transición
un gobierno de transición porque se
quiere un gobierno alcance no electo
porque hay pequeños grupos de partidos
políticos que cuando va a las elecciones
recogen cerco a 10 a 50 9% lo nuevo o
sea jamás va a ganar el poder jamás va a
ganar la presidencia y la única manera
de expresar
su poder es a través de gobiernos
profesores tuvimos hay un rosario de
gobiernos 47 que es un gobierno profesor
es un gobierno no directo es un gobierno
que no se puede tener conciencia porque
no se sabe que el bien y 12.000 concejos
la procesión organice una te va a haber
elección para ganar las elecciones para
la votación de abrir para cambiar la
constitución y dije yo en el ir hasta el
final de su mandato de sus hijos de sus
50 porque no no no se olvide en 2016
2017 quienes tuve el poder por suceder
hitler otra vez un gobierno provisorio
entonces ante más de ganar esencial al
parecer al parece que la historia que la
historia de haití es una eterna
transición después de finalizar la
dictadura de los duvalier 20 gobiernos
en 35 años de todo tipo de a usted lo
mencionaba gobiernos militares
antes de transición presidentes
interinos juntas de ministros también
influencia internacional es el país que
más ong tiene presencia en su territorio
que abarcan prácticamente todas las
arcas del gobierno y no se puede avanzar
en infraestructura y en proyectos porque
todo el dinero está en las ong y no los
tiene esos recursos no los tiene el
gobierno el panorama es muy complicado y
aquí hay un punto y una vuelta de tuerca
para terminar de agravar la situación
colette y es este paso que dio la
oposición de empezar a crear un gobierno
alterno un gobierno también de
transición un presidente transitorio
como tomar esta medida de la oposición o
un paso en falso un paso que les juega
en contra como que lectura si usted
bueno una primera cosa que yo quería
decir al contrario de lo que dice así
los descensos no pienso que la crisis es
solamente una cosa de elección y para mí
es más profundas tenemos en haití una
crisis permanente y lo que estamos
viviendo ahora es un cuerpo una nueva
cara de esta crisis permanente que
tenemos desde años lo casi desde la
independencia del país porque tenemos un
sistema de exclusión social y no es la
primera vez que hay conflicto con un
gobierno en el poder porque siempre hay
muchas desconfianza y siempre no hay
realmente una satisfacción de lo de los
en las necesidades del pueblo y por eso
siempre está y eso lleva a conflictos y
la última que tenemos es eso con un
gobierno sobre mandar los mandatarios en
cuestión pero también tenemos del otro
lado a una condición que hasta ahora no
está bastante organizada para dar una
respuesta que conviene realmente a la
situación de crisis permanente que
estamos viviendo y yo pienso que así
tenemos elecciones o elecciones muy bien
organizadas como por ejemplo lo que veía
la comunidad no lo quiere la comunidad
internacional la oea las canciones
hundida
eso no va a resolver el problema porque
más tenido ya en el pasado
a otros momentos de elecciones eso lo ha
resuelto el problema si no se toma en
cuenta pero la crisis profunda que es el
resultado de un sistema de exclusión
total de un pueblo que tiene hambre que
no tiene salud etcétera entonces la
oposición está enfrentado de dar su
respuesta pero no pienso que cuando un
nuevo un gobierno paralelo que esto
tampoco va a resolver la crisis que
tenemos ahora en ricardo en minutos le
doy la palabra quiero aprovechar y
recoger algunos de los argumentos que
usted dio y preguntarle a colette
entonces está usted de acuerdo en esa
sugerencia o ese comentario que hace
ricardo dejar que el presidente móvil
termine convoque a elecciones para
diciembre y en febrero el 7 de febrero
del 2022 entre un nuevo gobierno y que a
lo largo de este año la oposición se
organice ese puede ser entonces un
escenario válido
a quien se dice la pregunta es para ello
para disparar al colectivo
aunque bueno en las condiciones actuales
se necesita elecciones no para
renovarlas las personas que están
gobernando que sean en el parlamento en
los municipios y también la presidencia
pero si se hacen las elecciones en las
condiciones actuales eso va a agudizar
de nuevo agravar la crisis y nos va a
resolver nada porque si uno mira muy
bien la historia de los 20 ó 30 años
empezando desde la caída de duvalier
hemos tenido mucho más crisis cada vez
después de elecciones
y por qué ok son selecciones muy bien
hechas pero algún otro grupo que dan un
golpe de estado o que es la comunidad
internacional que intervienen
directamente para imponer a sus propios
candidatos y el señor y carlos tesi de
tiempos sabe mucho de esta historia
entonces necesitamos realmente
a tener una situación de más
ellos desde día de paz y donde aún hace
días de costas que estando con él ya es
exacto como poner las personas que están
en la cárcel
la restricción esa constitución que ha
tristemente él quiere imponer a la gente
no a un consenso sobre tener una nueva
una nueva constitución y todo eso sí
tenemos un consenso sobre eso va a
agravar la crisis inicial en las
elecciones en estas formaciones ricardo
le repito la pregunta que le hace a
colette y le pido sea breve porque voy
con dos preguntas para usted este paso
que dio la oposición de crear un
gobierno transitorio tienen un
presidente ya electo por su cuenta por
el lado de ellos sin preguntarle
consultarlo a los ciudadanos como
recibió no esta información usted que
perteneció a un organismo internacional
a un organismo continental
gobierna el sistema británico cuando la
oposición a la oposición se concentra en
cualquier sentido pero antes es
importante no sé muy bien lo que pasó
con algunos momentos de la historia
reciente aquí por ejemplo un golpe de
estado que quería dar la comunidad
internacional contra el presidente rené
préval 2010 yo mismo
lo que importa lo que importa es que la
oposición no tiene credibilidad la
oposición está desunida por otro lado
con lo que tiene de cierta manera razón
por decir que la selección no vale en
las cosas pero porque no valen las cosas
porque antes de las elecciones hay un
consejo electoral
debería ser permanente
electoral
la elección y la gente no lo acepta los
resultados las elecciones mira hay 165
partidos políticos con nuevas elecciones
hay 164 calidad e intereses santiago que
se quedan fuera pero a la oposición que
no vieron acción o sea nosotros y
américa latina
tuvimos una se está viendo españa
también portugal también es gracia
también en este europeo tuvimos una
experiencia de transición la dictadura
creo que hay
y todos esos movimientos son el pacto de
libertad y garantías democráticas
en el pasado
a mis tías y por otro lado para mirar
adelante las reglas del juego para usar
el poder
haití es el único país santiago que hace
35 años que estamos en esta casa no más
de 30 mil millones de dólares y nombre
de haití y todavía no hay este pacto
sintes de pacto no es posible hacer la
profesión
entonces los pequeños partidos a ellos
donde interesa su impacto porque cuando
se va de las elecciones y sean los
resultados se ve muy bien que yo
represento nada o casi nadie y puesto
que ellos quieren es siempre una crisis
de
este es su modus vivendi
hay tierra hecho por los pequeños
partido poderse quedar sacar de masa de
pequeños partidos de intereses de tener
una crisis permanente porque la crisis
permanente ellos pueden sacarle ventajas
ricardo y qué lectura hace usted del
presidente no es un presidente que
disolvió el parlamento en enero del 2020
ha reprimido de manera muy fuerte las
protestas de los ciudadanos a lo largo
de estos últimos meses
critica mucho este derecho a la protesta
y este derecho que tienen los ciudadanos
a discrepar con algunas políticas del
gobierno está gobernando prácticamente
por decreto ha aumentado
considerablemente esto lo puede
confirmar colette la inseguridad sobre
todo en puerto príncipe los secuestros
200 por ciento de incremento
qué balance puede hacer de este gobierno
interesante
es portador de para tanto
no tenía ninguna experiencia pero puede
llevar el poder por parte de parte del
poder por escrito o sea es una tarea
larga que no es el momento de votar pero
no tiene ninguna o poca experiencia creo
que algunas cosas buenos lo hacen
un campo 3 sistema que domina la
economía izquierda y hasta que en ti
está por detrás también de sus
manifestaciones ahora lo posiciona por
otro lado hay posibilidad de manifestar
por supuesto con nosotros conocemos en
democracia tenemos manifestaciones
muchas veces son se mueven violencia
trabajo violencia muertes e incendios
los ojos de esta moza y santiago
catorce mil policías para una población
de casi dos millones de habitantes es la
única fuerza pública que hay
no hay fuerzas armadas entonces ellos no
hay una responsabilidad y creo que tiene
mucha experiencia y mucha otra
manifestación
fue electo y dejando terminar su mandato
vamos
refiriendo sobre sobre la constitución
es fundamental es fundamental la
constitución de izquierda no deja ni el
presidente ni el parlamento de verdad
es un de servicio a la población y vamos
a salir elecciones del segundo semestre
pero la oposición tiene que organizarse
tiene que modernizar su campaña
electoral lo que no hace porque hay
muchos caciques como sigue siendo decir
y pocos indios y colette es viable para
usted ya estaba dando usted algunos
indicios algunos visos de la opinión que
tiene sobre esta reforma a la
constitución que está proponiendo el
presidente cuál es su opinión y
ampliemos entonces más
bueno la actual constitución que tenemos
es una constitución que fue votada de
manera masiva por el pueblo haitiano
después de la caída de duvalier y en
esta constitución se ha puesto muchas
cosas muy buenas sobre todo en lo que
tiene que ver con los derechos humanos y
también la justicia social es verdad que
hay muchas debilidades pero como en el
pasado en la historia del país y siempre
los presidentes que quieren ajustar las
constituciones para imponer sus propias
cosas en las constituciones han cambiado
los que habían escrito la potestad
constitucional y han puesto que no se
puede hacer mencionando es decir un voto
popular y ha puesto la manera como se
puede cambiar cosas en la constitución y
ahora es a la cual presidente
simplemente el cual
en un momento donde él está muy muy
contestado está intentando de hacer su
propia constitución porque en el país
hay un consenso que hay cosas que he
revisado
hay que revisar la constitución algunas
dicen que si hay que hacer una nueva
transmisión que hay que hacer revisada
sin hacer una nueva pero todo eso
necesita un consenso y aparecen el solo
núcleo tiene el poder del derecho la
constitución lo desdobló le da ese poder
de hacer la construcción
desgraciadamente en el mandato de las
del virus en la misión actual de las
naciones unidas habían puesto eso como
un elemento fundamental del apoyo de la
misión de las naciones unidas
actualmente que trabajan con el gobierno
para hacer la constitución
en otras la gente no está de acuerdo con
eso que al presidente le haga solo y en
dentro de esta crisis es difícil
sentarse y discutir que vamos a poder
realmente en la constitución yo estoy de
acuerdo con él siendo el poder este
falso sobre él el consejo lo electoral
yo pienso que necesitamos un consejo
electoral permanente para tener la
institución que organiza de manera
regular las elecciones también se
necesita ese corte
el consejo institucional para poder por
ejemplo decir
como el avanzar cuando a la crisis
volante que no casualmente sobre el
mandatario de la presidente pero el
sistema electoral hay que revisar
completamente yo pienso que el problema
de las elecciones está
en el sistema electoral y es un buen
sistema un sistema electoral
riccardo su opinión sobre este tema la
nueva constitución que propone el
presidente este sistema electoral ya
usted decía hay que tener un organismo
electoral permanente y no que se
conforme solamente para cuando hay
comicios
si crees que conecte tiene la
constitución del 37 que se consideraba a
tomar constitución ciudadano con muchos
derechos
el problema central de la constitución
es el modelo del régimen político porque
es semi presidencialista es ser
parlamentarios o sea déjame explicar
porque me quedan pocos minutos para
llegar a los combatieron esa vía no hay
necesidad de una doble mayoría para
gobernar una mayoría presidencial y el
presidente tiene que tener una mayoría
parlamentaria porque porque el
parlamento que va a definir quién es el
primer ministro y quién va a ser los
videos sobre el gobierno y entonces el
presidente puede ganar el palacio
presidencial pero puede no gobernar caso
no tenga una mayoría para la verdad
entonces la propuesta de dicho nivel
pero lo que sería un terminar con el
senado terminar con el parlamentarismo
sólo tener solamente los diputados
generales de potasa izquierdos y tener
un presidente y un vicepresidente
problema
francés de no decidir si es un
parlamentarismo hombres de ese mismo y
en el caso de que no esto no funciona
con leche para terminar las conclusiones
que cree usted que va a suceder tengo
pocos minutos para terminar el programa
por favor
sus conclusiones hay dos posibilidades
que se sentamos así que buscamos una
solución real para el futuro de nuestro
país y pienso que al pueblo lo necesita
o qué
se agudiza la crisis por luchar
violencia
pero esperamos que los dos actores van a
cantarte para buscar una solución
y ricardo su conclusión que va a suceder
en haití en los próximos meses cómo se
puede resolver entonces o cuál será el
resultado de esta crisis
una crisis permanente como siempre
by le dijo que iba a evaluar la
situación
recuerdo que se volvió también escrito a
los intereses sobre haití son muy
importantes
la pareja escrito la históricamente y la
política y tierra entonces yo creo que
no voy a cambiar la posición con la
internacional que pueden opinar que
poder
el referendo
sobre constitución y que apoyen la
organización de elecciones al final de
la y eso va a pasar así va a continuar
haber una manifestación pero no hay otro
camino y el otro camino se lleva
revolución
el otro camino sería la revolución y la
revolución no puede pasar porque
solamente 160 kilómetros que separan la
base de guantánamo de la cosa y que esto
no va a pasar están subidos a mano a
permitir france tampoco
entonces dentro de los límites de la
democracia con todas sus limitaciones y
defectos con lo que piensa usted esta
afirmación que una revolución allí no
puede suceder pero dado el grado de
descontento que hay entre los haitianos
las pocas posibilidades que tienen para
su futuro la pandemia del cob y 19 y las
dificultades a las que se tienen que
enfrentar en el día a día en un país que
produce poco alimento no tiene medicinas
el sistema de salud no funciona bien
podrían llegar a ese escenario tan
radical
no creí porque durante toda la carga
fría por ejemplo
con la situación que tenemos ahora pero
sobre todo porque algún día bajó a estar
muy apoyada por los poderosos como por
ejemplo los eeuu
eso puede ser el aguja muy difícil sin
embargo el boom haitiano no está
realmente visualmente aceptar cualquier
cosa es decir que la gente va a luchar
muchísimo y espero que llegamos el ver
de todo eso a un mínimo de consenso
entre nosotros los para resolver
nuestros problemas
a una significante que su respuesta es
una palabrita recuerdo en diciembre de
2019 instancia de los caladeros de
dominicana el ex representante de
naciones unidas en móvil y su conjunto
me dice para un par para los partidos de
extrema derecha para dominicanos y
haitianos diciendo que la única solución
para aquí es que el comando sur
con sus militares y dijo nosotros tengo
que hacer y eso sería rápidamente dinero
el reconocimiento del fracaso la
comunidad internacional
el segundo es crear una nueva situación
comunidad que sin aceptar
definitivamente haití sigue siendo la
deuda pendiente de los organismos
internacionales y también de la
comunidad latinoamericana y del
continente americano le ha faltado
unidad al continente para apoyar a este
país en estas crisis políticas a colette
en la ciudad de puerto príncipe muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
habernos contado su perspectiva de la
crisis allí en su país merci beaucoup
gracias por acompañarnos y también
ricardo seitenfus desde la ciudad de
brasilia la capital brasileña muchas
gracias también por haber compartido con
nosotros su perspectiva sobre la crisis
haitiana muy publicado ya ustedes
también muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado en el día de hoy aquí en el
debate de france 24 sigan dejando todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales pueden seguir con
nuestra programación hay más para ver en
france 24
[Música]